[Music]
season eight of HBO's Game of Thrones
has come to an end and a lot of people
including myself are pretty annoyed
about how it played out in this video
I'm going to break down the main reasons
why fans were left so disappointed by
what was supposed to be a fitting
conclusion to one of the greatest TV
shows of all time number one it was
rushed everything in season eight seemed
to be happening too quickly and it would
often feel like three episodes worth of
information was being crammed into one
feature-length episode a side effect of
this was that we weren't able to enjoy
the big payoff moments in the way that
we had previously for example in episode
1 of season 8
John rode Rhaegar this is something that
has huge significance but it didn't feel
like a big event and the reason is it
came halfway through an episode when
loads of other really important things
happened Jon was reunited with bran and
Arya fiance Viera the golden company
arrived in Westeros
Ned umber was killed by the White
Walkers Jaime Lannister turned up
unannounced at Winterfell and had a
stare-off with bran and Jon actually
learned that he was Aegon Targaryen heir
to the Iron Throne and nephew of his
lover Danny yeah a lot of stuff happened
in that episode when you compare this
moment when Daenerys first flew of
drogon it pales in insignificance
it was a climax of season 5 episode 9
and was part of a tense nine and a half
minute scene where Daenerys was ambushed
by the sons of the harpy in the fighting
pits of murine drogon who was previously
missing swooped down to protect Dany
before she climbed on his back and flew
away the early seasons of Game of
Thrones were dialogue heavy building up
characters and there wasn't much
on-screen action seasoned Ellie and to
some degree six and seven were not like
this at all number two character
development something that seemed like a
direct consequence of the rushed nature
of season eight was the jarring
character development which left us
feeling shocked confused and even
betrayed many would argue that the show
lost its way from season 5 onwards that
was the point that Benioff
vice started making the biggest
departures from George RR Martin's books
but season a has had by far the most
backlash here's why each and every
character had been painted so vividly up
until this point and within six episodes
some had changed beyond recognition the
best example of this is Daenerys
Targaryen we had seven seasons of
Daenerys Targaryen being built up as one
of the main heroes in the show and she
was torn down and destroyed in the final
three episodes and many fans of the show
felt betrayed by it I just want to make
it clear that this isn't me criticizing
the story arc if it was necessary for
Dany to become the mad Queen then that
is fine but it should not have happened
so quickly I think I could have gone
along with her downfall if I was
subjected to at least three episodes of
a decline following the death of miss
sandy I feel like we needed to see her
not eating not sleeping and growing more
and more paranoid and vengeful instead
what we got was a few shots of her
looking a bit tired with bags under your
eyes and a hair messed up this just
wasn't good enough when the bells rang
out around King's Landing and Dany
decided to burn down the city anyway
killing thousands of people in the
process it just didn't feel like a
decision that the Daenerys we'd followed
for eight seasons would make okay let's
move on to Jon Jon had the most screen
time throughout the whole show and
probably the most interesting character
arc as anyone else
the secret son of Rhaegar Targaryen and
Lyanna Stark the man who is an actual
mixture of Ice and Fire what was the
point of Jon being a Targaryen the big
reveal of this information was a huge
part of the narrative yet was only used
as a tool to partly justified the
descent of Daenerys into madness finally
on character development let's look at
Jaime Lannister the Kingslayer season
one's most loathed character was
transformed through our eight seasons as
we learned more and more about his past
and saw him perform Noble and selfless
acts this will peak when he deserted
Cersei to go on fight at Winterfell
to save Westeros from the night King and
the army of the Dead after this he again
deserts the lover Brienne this time to
go and save Cersei but this move isn't
quite the selfless act that the previous
one was
and actually reduces a lot of the hard
work that was put into building him up
were we supposed to think that this
commitment to his sibling was noble it
certainly didn't seem it three
anticlimactic moments by far the biggest
anticlimactic moment for me in season 8
was death of the knight King
yes the battle was huge and
cinematically beautiful when you
brightened it up a little bit but it
wasn't what some Game of Thrones fans
were waiting for here's why the opening
scenes of season 1 episode 1 showed
members of the Night Watch going beyond
the wall and coming face to face with a
white Walker the side narrative
throughout the show was that the wars
between wannabe kings of Westeros were
actually nothing compared to the threat
that was building beyond the wall when
we were introduced to the night king he
immediately became the ultimate villain
incredibly powerful and seemingly
undefeatable so when this enemy was
defeated midway through season 8 it
seemed like a bit of an anti-climax not
to mention the way in which it happened
first of all we didn't get to see any of
the skilled swordsman battling with the
night king nor his henchmen I just want
to make it clear I have no problem with
Arya being the person who killed the
night king I actually really like this
but we would tease this main event of
Jon and the night king having a battle
he didn't get to fight him at hardhome
he didn't get to fight him on the lake
and it just felt like the Battle of been
Winterfell was where it was going to
happen yet what we got was Jon chasing
him around and being blocked by an
undead dragon and the night king not
fighting anyone and then being killed
without a battle
by Arya it just felt a little bit like
an anti-climax to me another anticlimax
myself was the death of Cersei and Jaime
the story arc of the sibling lovers
threatened more than once to end in
betrayal or murder but in the end the
two were killed by falling rocks while
trying to run away from Daenerys and
drones fire frenzy on the red keep a
little bit of a let
another anticlimax was John ending up
back at the Nights Watch I know this is
a circular story and george RR martin
does like those but it didn't feel like
it was what his character deserved john
had an epic storyline with his true
heritage revealed as Aegon Targaryen but
it all came to nothing and he found
himself back at Castle black
going ranging with the wildlings despite
Arya killing the night king I do feel
like she was underused in this series
since killing the phrase we never saw
her use her faceless training again
which could have been for some more
interested in viewing than seeing her
ride off on a random white horse it was
pretty anticlimactic for myself that the
unsullied and the Dothraki just left the
final episode shows the unsullied and
Dothraki armies hyped for more wars at
the star but ends with them leaving in
boats watching the person who killed
their queen walk past without doing
anything they say times a healer but I'm
not sure it works wonders like that for
plot holes season 8 was Game of Thrones
final season so all of the loose ends
should have been tied up and the
audience shouldn't be left asking
questions right wrong here are just a
few that are keeping me up at night so
what about bran becoming King as much as
I personally like this twist it was a
little unbelievable due to the way that
it happened especially when all the
people deciding seem to have a far more
obvious choice Tyrion loves stories
right and who had a better story than
brans dark
how about Jon Jon went from stark
bastard to Lord Commander to King in the
north he was literally killed and
resurrected he was the prince that was
promised who slayed his lover for the
good of the realm now let's send that
guy to the Nights Watch where he can
watch over what exactly no one even
talked about him as a possibility when
they were choosing the next leader of
Westeros the reason for this it was part
of an agreement to please the unsullied
and Yara Greyjoy who felt that Jon
should be punished for killing Daenerys
while this is understandable to a
certain degree it feels Hollow as the
unsullied have seen minutes later
boarding
ship to the Isle of nath and the
Greyjoy's were not a powerful enough
house did a man this sort of respect
from the other lords of westeros Sansa
and Arya both had great stories worthy
of becoming Queen but again neither of
them were mentioned
so bran became King but how can the
three-eyed raven actually become King
anyway bran went from the strange
emotionless person who would stare
blankly before saying something that
made others feel uncomfortable to the
king of Westeros and none of the
characters even batted an eyelid
the last three-eyed raven lived north of
the wall and merged with a tree
why is brand so different that's just
another thing that isn't explained who
is the Prince of Dorne how did he come
to power and why are the Martel's
suddenly so unimportant in season a
despite being such a big focus of
earlier seasons and finally why does the
Nights Watch even exist anymore the
White Walkers are wiped out wildlings
are allies the wall is destroyed near
East Watch and various castles along the
wall are unmanned is there any point in
restoring them five forgotten characters
it became very clear in the final
seasons that a few characters really
served no purpose to the final outcome
of the show where's jaqen H'ghar
the faceless man is one of the
characters who trained Arya Stark at the
end of season six he let her go back to
Westeros and we haven't heard from him
since
what about Daario naharis the former
lover of Daenerys was left in Mereen at
the end of season six to keep an eye on
the city we never heard from him again
surely his men could have been used in
the battle against the dead apparently
not
and what about ilaria stand at the end
of season seven Ilario son was left to
watch a daughter die in front of her in
the red keep
we never saw or heard from her again six
unrealistic events yes I am going to go
there in a show about dragons magic and
the undead I'm gonna call out some
unrealistic things that happened don't
worry the irony isn't lost on me first
of all let's talk about how far area
must have had to jump to kill the night
king yeah that looks like a long way I
know she has skills but that seems
how about when Danny didn't see your on
ships from half a mile high this
unlikely ambush resulted in Rhaegar
being killed at Danny's chances of
taking King's Landing being reduced one
of the positives about having a dragon
should be that you can see things coming
apparently not during this ambush dragon
and Danny fled from Euron's ships but
when it came to taking King's Landing
the pair destroyed his whole fleet with
ease along with all the scorpions on the
wall at King's Landing why didn't they
just do that before remember when bran
aggressively threatened Tyrion and Jaime
with a crossbow well apparently that was
forgiven pretty easily following the
burning of King's Landing
what about Undead this area so undead
for sehri on burned through the wall
which had protected the Seven Kingdoms
for years but he couldn't burn through a
mound of stones to kill Jon Snow so
number seven the changing of the main
villain from episode three to six we saw
three different main villains the night
King at the Battle of Winterfell
Cersei during episode four and five and
finally Daenerys in Episode six this
quick switching between the antagonists
was a little confusing and it wasn't
helped by the lack of time for all of
these events to sink in eight character
deaths alright so I think this show
would have actually been better with
more of the main characters dying Game
of Thrones lost a lot of its
unpredictability when it was drawing to
a close the show has done it over and
over again killing main characters yeah
it seemed pretty obvious that the key
characters were going to survive the
Battle of Winterfell as it was clear
that their storylines still needed to
play out I never felt like there was a
danger that Jon Dany Tyrion Sansa or
Arya might die in the battle which is
something that just wouldn't have
happened in previous seasons 9
continuity mistakes yes this season had
quite a few the most memorable was the
coffee cup in plain sight on the table
after the Battle of Winterfell there are
also two modern-day water bottles on the
floor in the scene
or Braca Stoneking something that many
fans noticed is the inconsistency of the
way the king's landing was depicted all
of these are apparently the same city
yet they don't look anything alike
and finally eagle-eyed viewers spotted
that Daenerys was wearing different wigs
when she arrived at Winterfell in season
8 episode 1 let me know in the comments
if you think I missed anything or if you
disagree altogether